[Музика]
так зволікайте, отримайте каттілін, але
торт — це Lucia SSDs manikaran Pina
monitor OS :
todo su pregnant nourished SME for
bootable which Nia творчо чистий
дохід маркер чату, так що хлопці, як ви бачите,
я одягнений, і ви можете здогадатися  правильна тема
ми будемо говорити про Гаррі
Поттера і магію, тож давайте почнемо
магію правильно Мені дуже сподобався наш урок
з Марічкою минулого разу, тому я
запрошу її на урок я готовий мені потрібна
ваша допомога для цього чи можете ви сказати
абракадабра  зі мною
давайте спробуємо Abra Cadabra це не спрацювало,
тому що вона не допомогла мені, давайте спробуємо
ще раз
1 2 3 Abra Cadabra Вау, яка перерва на каву
так, так як ви бачите, що ви в
класі, вибачте, що перериваю ваш день,
що ви були  я пила
каву, але це така приємна зміна,
тож ти хочеш провести ще один
урок з нами, звичайно, добре, тож почнемо,
дозволь мені зняти сукню, тож ходімо ми
продовжуємо розмову про книги, яким був
твій вірш, мій вірш  чудово мої діти
Я був вражений, коли я прочитав деякі такі фантастичні,
то чи вони пам'ятають вірш про
шоколад так фантастично сьогодні ми говоримо
про Гаррі Поттера
, чи ти читав книжки про Гаррі Поттера не
дуже багато, тому що, як сказали б британці,
це не моя чашка чаю,
добре, я повинен  не відставай від моїх дітей,
тому
я повинен знати, про що йдеться в
основах, ти дивився фільм так, я дивився, але
я манекен про Гаррі Поттера, це добре, це
добре, наприклад, якщо ви запитаєте мене, я не
читав усіх книг, мабуть, одну  або дві
і одну книгу я читав англійською, а
другу я читав українською, але я
подивився всі фільми, щоб я міг говорити
про її репортера, добре, тож давайте подумаємо
про прикметники, які спадають вам на
думку, коли ви чуєте слово Гаррі Поттер
її  звіт і книги про Гаррі Поттера, тож я
даю вам 10 15 секунд подумайте
про прикметники prick madnikey okay okay,
тож давайте перейдемо до слова магія я
люблю магію марійка чи віриш ти в
магію я добре, тому багато людей кажуть,
що є  ніякої магії  у нашому житті, але я
безперечно вірю в різдвяний дух,
тому я кажу, що це чарівна пора
року, що ви думаєте про магію
взагалі я роблю все можливе, щоб мої
діти дуже вірили в магію в
Різдво Дід Мороз прямо на
одязі  у зубній феї
AHA так Nevaeh doc мм-хм, це дуже
приємно, тож давайте подумаємо над словами
магія, у нас є п'ять букв Маріка,
ви можете допомогти мені назвати букви M ma GIC
так, давайте подумаємо про прикметники,
які починаються з цих букв,
наприклад  яке слово спадає тобі на думку,
коли ти чуєш букву М німий
ладно це мовчить що ще
чудове добре сучасна сучасна велика Мері
крім заміжньої це вечір
із салатом дозвольте мені написати слово, тому
що це дуже типова помилка, ви
плутаєте це слово
Ері, чому це весело так, а мама, це я,
Мері, так, Мері, Мері, справа від Марії,
стати чиїмось чоловіком для дружини так, так,
якщо ви хочете сказати, що це
щось смішне цікаве, скажіть Марія
або ваша і напишіть це  з E, якщо ви
хочете згадати, що ця особа
виходить заміж, тому ви використовуєте a в цьому
світі, будьте обережні, добре, так що щодо aa
авантюрний гарний веселий добре адаптований
гарний молодець
дивовижно правильно давайте підемо з G чудова
чудова
Джейн Холл вдячна гарна милостива
ммм-  хм, просто чудово, чудово, славно, так
добре, як щодо i-ight вражаюче
добре так,
величезний ммм-хм, ти думаєш про
синонім слова розумний розумний
Браво молодець і достовірний також
правий правильний вірогідний це прекрасне
слово дивіться розумний добре
заразний Вау  це тому, що я б пішов на
це так
милий компетентний створюй креатив молодець,
так що давайте подивимося на мої слова, у
мене є дивовижний дивовижний чудовий
неймовірний і милий, добре
, навіщо мені тут потрібні прикметники, тому що
ми будемо говорити про головних героїв
з книги чи пам'ятаєте ви якихось
героїв з книги, звісно, поспішайте, Га
рі, скупі люди, а хто во
и?  З усіх у нас є
троє друзів правильно Гаррі Поттер
повторюй за мною Гаррі Поттер добре давайте
спробуємо ще раз Гаррі Поттер
молодець і давайте з наступним,
як моє коліно Грейнджер це дуже
цікаво, тому що зазвичай люди
вимовляють твою ногу новим власником так і
це насправді невірно, тому що
британці кажуть, Герміона, давайте скажемо
ще раз Герміона
молодець Герміона Ґрейнджер - Герміона
Грейнджер так, і третій друг Роланд
Візлі фантастичний, і у нас є
професор Альбус Дамблдор, Альбус
Дамблдор, добре, всі ці персонажі
позитивні, чи можете ви описати  ці
персонажі, які використовують прикметники, які ми
обговорювали на початку уроку,
вони чарівні мужні мм-хм,
давайте по одному, наприклад, я думаю, що
Гаррі я думаю, що Гаррі дуже креативний,
добре,
Герміона,
Герміона, добре, давайте повторимо за мною,
давай  вона - Герміона
скажімо голосно Герміона Герміона
фантастична Герміона дуже інноваційна
добре Рон Візлі дуже мудрий мм-хм і
Альбус Дамблдор дуже розумний, розумний, і
я думаю, що він дуже чесний, справедливий, чесний
справедливий, і він також дуже щедрий,
щедрий, що це означає, щедрий,
добрий, так, сука Лілі, добре, давайте
поговоримо про негативних персонажів. Мені не
подобається слово негатив, але в  книга,
вони повинні бути схожими на злих, добре,
тож перше, чи можете ви допомогти мені
Маріска Драко Мелфой так правильно
Долорес Амбридж так лорд Волдеморт так
лорд Волдеморт то що є найбільшим
злом у цьому списку Долорес Долорес я
думаю, що Балтимор добре
ось хто не повинен бути Нет
Нейт правильно народжений, якого не можна називати
добре, давайте по одному Драко
Мелфой насправді друг дітей друг
Гаррі друг Герміона і друг Рон,
я можу сказати, дійсно великий друг, але
він його школа  товариш, вони вчаться разом,
але байдужа команда, тому Гаррі
Герміона та Рон вони з
грифіндорської команди, а Драко з
команди Слизерин, добре, так як ви можете
описати Драко, якщо пам'ятаєте, що він один
із  біле волосся, я б сказав, що він
нечесний, лицемірний мм-хм,
значить, мм-хм, також трохи лукавий, добре, а як
щодо Лорас у фільмі, я пам’ятаю, що
вона була в дуже гарному рожевому костюмі, тому
я можу точно сказати, що вона мила, але
Говорячи про її характер, вона мила,
але я б знову сказав, що це означає, ммм-хм і
небезпечно, небезпечно так, це дуже
гарне слово, а про лорда Волдеморта він
злісний,
добре, так, і знову я вірний, жорстокий,
так і непередбачуваний, непередбачуваний,
звичайно, добре, тому давайте  Переходьте до того, як звіти
книга дуже важлива, тому що я
кажу, що важливо, тому що багато дітей
там є пацієнти, так, вони живуть
з вони мають свої костюми, вони
носять плаття, вони використовують чарівну паличку
кожен день, так як  репортери-вчителі
правильно дають різні життєві уроки, тож
давайте поговоримо про це, подивіться на
номер один вибирайте друзів мудро, що
це означає, вибирайте друзів мудро, як
ви можете зрозуміти цю расу, що
слід бути дуже обережним, вирішуючи, хто
o подружитися з okay, тому не довіряйте,
мабуть, з самого початку.
Хороший вчитель - це чудова річ
, тому що хороший вчитель, ймовірно, може бути
однією з найбільших цін, які ви отримуєте у
своєму житті, він або вона навчить вас дуже
багато речей, які ви можете використовувати у своєму
житті, якими ви можете рости з мм-хм і
стати  ким ви хочете бути, якщо ми
подивимося на цю конкретну фразу, ми
говоримо про шкільних вчителів чи
вчителів загалом, я думаю, що загалом
хороший вчитель може бути не
може бути не може бути не тільки шкільним вчителем, але
другом, батьком або, ймовірно, незнайомцем
О, Ерік, кухар, тому що ти любиш
правильно готувати і ти любиш вчитися готувати,
тож, ймовірно, відомий кухар також може бути вашим
вчителем.
твої страхи, ну, марно ховатися від своїх
страхів, тому що рано чи пізно тобі
доведеться зіткнутися з цим, це зіткнення зі своїми страхами – це
перший крок до подолання страхів
, будь сміливим і зіткнися зі своїми страхами,
просто зроби це багато людей, пишіть мені, як
Наталія  Мені страшно, що я хочу вивчити
англійську, але я не впевнений, що
зроблю це, просто зіткнуся зі своїми страхами, і просто зроби
це, краще діяти, ніж не діяти, тому
давайте йти далі, якщо вам потрібна допомога, попросіть
її.  Я думаю, що не найсильніша
риса українського народу
просити допомоги, тому що нам соромно просити,
щоб він виглядав некомпетентним чи слабким
мм-хм, і добре просити
допомоги, якщо вона потрібна, це не соромно
це не соромно це  правильний вчинок
для мене, коли ви просите про
допомогу, це означає, що
людина дійсно сильна, ви не
втрачаєте обличчя, якщо ви просите
допомоги, вам потрібно бути дійсно сильним, щоб
попросити її, щоб мати можливість  щоб запитати, ніби я не
професійний на даний момент,
будь ласка  допоможіть мені, тому що мені потрібно
подолати це, це нормально, просити
допомоги, і останній будь діячем, а не
мрійником, це складна фраза насправді
я збираюся попросити вашої допомоги, тому що я
не знаю цього слова добре, що означає  це
означає робити ой добре я розумію я чую
людину, яка не знає так так так так так
добре я просто не впізнала ні ні
все добре, краще почати
щось робити, а не тільки планувати,
мріяти чи говорити про це  так, але я
хочу запитати вас про слово мрія, якщо
ви подивитеся на це бути виконавцем, а не мрійником,
чи означає це, що вам взагалі не потрібно
мріяти ні насправді
першим кроком вашого успіху є ваша
мрія так  якщо ви не мрієте
, ви не можете рухатися вперед і робити
щось велике, якщо ви не задумали це спочатку
тому, якщо у вас є мрія, ви
Courvoisier academia pichan, я був би
досить ро  tten at nail rabbit perchik
rocío Сонце дуже добре Ясу популярний
ні Франція Україна крик ой так звичайно
кончина Вільям справді зайнятий сьогодні ввечері
сама красуня не так на моторі
місто великий підійшов до UNA пріянка
так пам'ять бідолашний хлопець вибір Роббі добре
тому я можу пояснити, що англійською це означає бути
виконавцем, а не мрійником,
ладно, ходімо далі, я хочу, щоб ви
зараз подивилися епізод, це
головна героїня епізоду,
буде Долорес, добре, а потім ми поговоримо
про її слова розмова про магію
теоретичні знання та практичні
знання давайте подивимось
[Музика]
доброго ранку діти
звичайні екзамени рівня чарівництва О,
хто знає більше, відомі як сови,
старанно вчиться, і ви будете винагороджені, якщо цього
не зробите і  наслідки можуть бути
серйозними. Ваші попередні інструкції з цього
предмета були тривожно нерівномірними, але
радий знати, що відтепер ви будете
слідувати ретельно структурованому
курсу визначення, затвердженого міністерством  енсивна
магія так, тут немає нічого про
використання захисних заклинань із використанням заклинань. Я
не можу уявити, чому вам потрібно використовувати
заклинання в моєму класі, ми не будемо
використовувати магію, ви будете вивчати
захисні заклинання безпечним
способом без ризику
яка користь від того, що якщо на нас
нападуть, то небезпечні студенти
піднімуть руки, коли вони будуть говорити
в моєму класі, я зупинюся на цьому, тому, коли
ми говорили про Долорес, вона згадала,
що ти хочеш, щоб вона  студенти
використовувати теоретичні знання, а насправді не
практикують, і Х'ю сказав, що
це означає, що ми не будемо використовувати магію і
не будемо практикувати заклинання, то
що ви думаєте про цю теорію чи
практику, я за поєднання  і
теорія, і практика, наприклад, я
для себе я абсолютно практична людина,
але без теорії ми можемо навчитися
чогось, чого я просто не знаю, мм-хм, тому нам
потрібна ідеальна комбінація, і це
буде 50-50  комбінація, я б
сказав, що так, але іноді я худую  k про
маленьких дітей, які говорять англійською лише
тому, що вони народилися
в Сполучених Штатах чи Великобританії,
вони не мають жодних теоретичних
знань про існування, тобто вони
говорять англійською краще, ніж ми
думаємо про ваші уроки кулінарії
скільки теорія  чи є у вас і скільки
у вас практики, я б сказав, що 10%
теорії і 90% практики так, тому
це насправді залежить від того, чи правильно ми думатимемо
про урок англійської мови, тому, ймовірно,
практика більше, а теорія менш
правильна, і якщо ми говоримо про  маса 5050
5050, ймовірно, тому, що вам потрібно знати
формули так, щоб розв'язувати проблеми, якщо ми
говоримо, наприклад, про урок історії,
добре, ви можете практикувати історію давніх
часів, я маю на увазі, що ви не можете, тому це,
ймовірно, буде більше теорії, ніж опікуни
побоюються, добре  дуже цікаве запитання
уроки хімії та урок фізики
ну діти скажуть, що вони
більше для практики, він особливий у
хімії так, вчителі кажуть, що їм
потрібна і теорія, так, так це
залежить від предмета англійською, я
б сказав, більше практики,
вам потрібно більше говорити, потрібно більше писати, намагайтеся
говорити кожен день, дивіться фільми англійською,
читайте книги англійською, і тоді ви
отримаєте більше знань, ви станете більш
обізнаними, тому давайте поговоримо про корисне
фрази, які ми насправді можемо підібрати
з книг, давайте поговоримо про
деякі практики, тому перше слово
подивіться тут, це насправді не слово так,
це питання, яке магічне слово,
гм,
я пам’ятаю свою маму, коли вона була, коли я
був молодим  і вона говорила мені
щось на зразок, що я хочу їсти печиво,
і було наче мама, мама, дай мені
печиво, і вона згадувала це,
що таке магічне слово, ах хітинова лава,
і, будь ласка, дайте мені печиво, щоб ми використали
це правильно, яке магічне слово  будь ласка,
дякую, так, тому ми насправді чекаємо,
поки людина дасть нам додаткове слово,
магічне слово тут означає це слово вдячності,
приємне слово, подібне до цього, тож давайте
з чарівним словом, я його напишу
вниз чарівне слово, що таке чарівне слово, давайте
перейдемо до цього, щоб помахати чарівною
паличкою, тож у мене є чарівна паличка, і я
махаю чарівною паличкою, що для вас означає,
як ви можете пояснити цю фразу, щоб
помахати  чарівна паличка я маю на увазі в реальному житті
мм-хм,
щоб досягти чогось дуже легко так,
як цей хлопець чарівник мм-хм,
наприклад, є правильна ситуація,
і ви хочете виправити її дуже швидко, щоб
вирішити проблему, тому можете просто помахати рукою
чарівна паличка і ми закінчили або, наприклад,
ви хочете рухатися швидше, наприклад
, у вас затор, ви
застрягли, але, маніпулюючи вибаченнями,
я не курю, співучасник групи Lazzara Дорма,
тож ви можете сказати, що я хочу помахати  чарівна
паличка це дуже корисна фраза, щоб
помахати чарівною паличкою, давайте перейдемо до цього,
щоб діяти як магія, це буде дуже
ефективно
так точно виключно ефективне так
надзвичайно, якщо ефективно працювати як
зачарування, чи можете ви придумати речення
або ситуацію  у реальному житті, де ми можемо
це використовувати, я маю на увазі, що вони онлайн  навчальна
школа в Україні працює як чарівна
фантастика Мені дуже подобається ваш приклад,
тож давайте запишемо, щоб він працював як
магія добре давайте витягнемо
кролика з капелюха це насправді у
вас є капелюх і зазвичай чарівник
або чарівник  вони витягують кролика
з капелюха, але як це
образна зустріч, давайте давайте з
реалістичністю, як ви це розумієте, щоб
продемонструвати деякі
очікувані та виняткові навички або
щось добре зроблено, тому насправді
просто скажіть мені правильно витягнути кролика
просто скажи мені, що
на ньому, щоб щури розкрити всі частини,
щоб покласти всі машини на стіл
так молодці, давайте рухатися далі,
будьте дракони, це з книги та
з фільму, будь дракони хто  це
дракон, це казковий герой так, і
він позитивний чи негативний, як правило,
лякає мм-хм, негативно правильно, так що в
реальному житті ви можете сказати, наприклад, гм, я
б не пішов туди, якби я був тут, будьте
дракони, так що це щось таке  g що ви
хочете запобігти тому, щоб перші люди потрапили в таку
страшну ситуацію, тому не йдіть
туди, це страшно або може бути небезпечно,
як це тут be dragons, можливо
завантажений запис, так що це просто
небезпечно тут be dragons давайте запишемо
це так  він Акаша розповідає шаблон Я
маю на увазі Паллаві так, так, так, так, так, так, так,
але якщо ви використовуєте мову Гаррі Поттера
або магія, а слова були тут
дракони, давайте перейдемо до того, щоб мати жабу
в горлі, що означає мати
жабу в епізоді  нашого репортера, коли
вони передають жабу, вони насправді
не могли говорити через те, що
через жабу, тому що жаби я маю на увазі,
тому що вони були приголомшені або тому, що
вони не могли фізично говорити, вони
не могли фізично говорити, тому коли у вас
є жаба  в горлі це означає,
що ти не можеш говорити, у тебе немає
слів, які ти заблокував, скажімо, ніби
в мене в горлі жаба, так що я ніби
нічого не можу вимовити, я шокований,
коли є жаба  одне горло,
якщо я говорю a  бо я буду у
мене жаба в горлі, якщо я буду говорити
про вас,
хлопці, у вас зламано горло правильно,
тому ми замінюємо слово один раз на
займенник чи можете ви сказати фразу про вас,
марійка, у мене жаба в горлі
Я буду мати жабу в печі
в горлі, коли я побачу голос
країни сьогодні ввечері
о, я бачу, я не можу уявити, як вони
збираються це
робити онлайн  одним штрихом давайте запишемо
це я скорочу це зламане одне
горло добре, давайте далі, нехай кота
з мішка
мм-хм, так що це також для того, щоб витягнути кролика
з капелюха і показати, дозволити кота
зі спини  добре, ми дозволимо щось
йти так точно
розкрий твій інтерес правильно просто
скажи нам правду
процвітаюча кримінальна проблема
хмара хвиля бачиш карикатуриста ти гарчиш не
випускай кота з мішка чи можеш ти
відверто сказати, що ця гонка просто скажи  це
дозволило котам вставати з ліжка, так, я
не збираюся випускати свого кота  з моєї сумки я
хочу зберегти це в секреті добре, це
гарна фраза, тому вони залишилися поза межами,
молодці, і давайте подивимося на цю
, щоб змусити нас у повітрі мати
якісь плани, які не можуть
статися мріями  насправді я насправді так само,
щоб бути мрійником, не десь
точно дякую, тому я
насправді люблю будувати повітряні замки,
тому я думаю, мрію і уявляю речі,
а потім все добре, Наталія, повертайся на землю,
це недобре робити  повітряні замки,
але час від часу все гаразд,
тому створюй повітряні замки
добре, давайте подивимося на цей О,
багато місяців тому багато місяців тому, це
ніби давно, давно, так, це
схоже на те, що це слова  тому так,
все, ви можете просто сказати, якщо ви
хочете підкреслити, що це було давно в
минулому, тому ви просто скажіть, що це було багато місяців
тому, правда, кілька днів тому, просто багато
місяців, є дуже приємні враження,
давайте з цим смаком або своїм  власні
ліки це цікавий
мм-хм смак та  Стес, ймовірно, живе
ні, ваш магазин запитав до Френсіса,
хто, ймовірно, сильно просочує витік.
мм-хм будь-які ідеї давайте уявіть собі
ситуацію, що є погана людина
так, і коли ви ставитеся до
чогось поганого, іноді ви отримуєте ті ж
ліки в  ваше горло, яке не має
гарного смаку, міс Метсон, зазвичай не смакує
так, тож це щось на зразок того, що ця
людина поводиться погано з вами чи з
іншою людиною, і це насправді як
помста, право на смак або власний
Метсон, людина поводилася погано  і він
або вона отримували так само, тому ця
людина смакує так, що він весь Метсон, а не
гіркота дитячий стіл так, мені подобається
ця комбінація, добре, так що
насправді вони менше, я напишу це тут,
Метсон, право спробувати за смаком
свого власного  медицина правильно, давайте
подивимося на ці фрази, щоб ми мали десять із
них чарівне слово, щоб помахати чарівною паличкою, щоб
працювати як магія, щоб витягнути кролика
з капелюха, ось дракони, плаття, а
одне горло випустити кота з  мішок
будувати замки в рік багато місяців тому
і скуштувати власного Метсона так що
зворотні фрази, які фрази ти
збираєшся підняти сьогодні марійка до свого
реального життя
до моїх повітряних замків, щоб скуштувати мої
власні ліки
добре і  витягти кролика з капелюха
добре, я також люблю багато місяців тому, тому це
звучить так вишукано,
добре іноді, коли ти говориш багато
місяців тому, і для мене створюється враження,
що ти дуже старий ні я не
я  не буду використовувати це, добре, тому, хлопці,
насправді я чую дзвінок, оскільки це
означає, що нам потрібно припинити урок, тож
давайте продовжимо домашнє завдання, я б хотів
, щоб ви написали власні приклади з
корисними фразами з нашого уроку, щоб у нас
було 10 з них  подумайте про реальні
ситуації, де ви можете використовувати ці
фрази, і на наступному уроці ми
їх обговоримо дуже дякую за
урок дуже дякую, це було так
приємно,
тепер ви можете повернутися до своєї кави,
дякую, до побачення, це так  моя Анна
Махасабха душасана Про в  oasty
kamiya-san Адам Гаррі Поттер
Ілана Маха – святковий покупець у MC з
підносом з куркою, а Меджіа візьме
вас, хто справді святкує дзеркала рову, ми
надаємо ностальгічні небс дуже
зображуємо намаху окружність мистецтва Нана
Гаррі Поттер як Наньян англійська
[Музика]
ти